President Biden invited himself in a
free fall after another bruising week
his administration racking up losses
after a judge pulled his Transportation
Mass mandate and Democrats revolted over
his plan to end title 42 which could
lead to an even bigger surge at the
border two major election forecasters
now predicting a red wave and are
shifting their projected outcomes for
several house races towards a GOP CNN
soaking it all up with this headline
it's been a very bad few days for Joe
Biden and the president's job
performance not inspiring confidence
there's a poll that was done about a
month ago in which the Democrats are are
in Congress are stunningly underwater
they're simply not a belief in among the
American people that the Democrats are
well equipped to handle pretty much any
problem at the moment and while Biden
has been telling allies he has game for
a 2024 run others are not so certain
some in the media now saying the bench
to replace him is not looking promising
and Kamala Harris once again the topic
of ridicule after delivering this speech
about space
I think everyone here recognizes how
extraordinary space is
whether it is satellites that orbit the
Earth
humans that land on the moon or
telescopes that peer into the furthest
reaches of the universe
space is exciting
waiting in the wings Bernie Sanders a
socialist Senator not ruling out another
run for the White House if President
Biden decides not to run for re-election
Greg yes we're not child actors behind
the vice president yeah she's always
she's into space she loves space because
she's had a load of it between her ears
does that mean no that's mean that's me
she's a smart lady but she talks like we
asked her where babies came from like
I'm ready there's a stork that land that
dropped you off on mommy's porch okay I
get memories of Romper Room when she's
talking it's so remember Robert room
with the like was that just California
you know what I'm gonna move on I'm
looking at this okay so you see you see
uh Hillary was supposed to come back got
Bernie you got me this this is the
Democratic bench is thinner than Chris
Wallace's demo reel from CNN Plus
it's right then thanks I just needed to
get that in there but it now I'm going
to be a pessimist the country's in
pretty bad shape uh with inflation with
crime mental health I think is one of
the biggest issues of our time and in
every one of those the Dems have kind of
made it worse even knowing the outcome
if you look at like as crime rage they
still defunded and demoralized the
police that's inflation Rose they Inc
they just printed more money a half a
trillion of it disappearing a half a
trillion that's got to be one inflation
point right and then you look in the
city streets and you look uh
you look at social media we have an
epidemic of mental illness going on and
you can't put people into therapy or
into treatment because that's a
violation of their rights so even I
guess what I'm getting at is even if one
Democrat wins that's insane because if
this is probably the greatest
opportunity for the Republicans to
actually clear the table if that's the
right phrase because those metrics I
mentioned are so important the only
thing that will stop it is if the media
decides to take those metrics off the
table right like they did with Hunter's
laptop or create a new hoax which I've
been trying to figure out what that next
hoax is going to be because there's
going to be a big one I don't know what
it is I mean the Russian collusion fine
people hoax what is it going to be
that's going to demonize all Republicans
maybe it'll have something to do with
space or it could be out of this world
yes it could be a satanic secret cult
um Harold I noticed that the the whole
thing about Bernie Sanders saying he's
going to run again I was listening to a
podcast earlier and they said this memo
about Bernie Sanders leaked no it didn't
it was purposefully given to the media
so that the story would get out there
and so that Bernie Sanders can continue
to raise money do you think Bernie
Sanders at 80 years old believes he's
going to run for president in 2024. I
read a Nick first of all it's good to be
back around the table I read an excerpt
from I wish I'd been here for the phone
yesterday too I read an excerpt uh
saying that that Sanders Bernie Sanders
met with President Obama President Obama
said that you're like an old Prophet Old
Testament Prophet Old Testament prophets
don't get to be kings in the New
Testament uh and you should accept that
you've had a big impact on the party you
can't tell anyone what to do and Bernie
Sanders certainly has a strong set of
opinions I think he is a serious guy but
I sometimes think his ideas are not
serious and if he were to run uh if Joe
Biden didn't run I think you'll have uh
you think Biden will run again I said I
think he said if Biden did but do you
think Biden Biden will run again and I
look forward to supporting him I think I
do really you think he's going to run
again I do think he's going to run again
and if he doesn't run again to Democrats
we'll have a we'll have a free-for-all I
think that's when you enter the picture
I think a couple of things I saw on the
poll title 42 Democrats hear me out very
briefly do not not suspend title 42
unless we have a real plan to deal with
the Border we should develop a plan that
deals with investing in that part of the
hemisphere as many of us are saying and
we should find ways to protect our
border this is not a it's a humanitarian
crisis but it's a national security
issue first and foremost crime we're
kidding ourselves as a party if we don't
believe that people all across this
country are concerned about guns
concerned about Bill reform concern
about something that Greg mentions on
this show very often uh concerns that we
have here in New York around mental
health uh and as as the judges said many
times before we ought to prosecute the
crimes that are on the books and if we
have to swell our jails we should we
should swell them three I'd say
something to the Republicans you're not
going to win just jumping on Democrats
all the time if you don't have big ideas
and I would say the Democrats as well
Big Ideas around how we invest in cities
to create new jobs to get people off
their behinds and get to work to want to
innovate we're not going to be the
country we should be in any the party
that does that best Greg I think is the
party that's going to win the money
already had to retain it or win it but
Democrats be clear about one thing crime
in the Border if we don't deal with
those issues we start at a massive
disadvantage uh in the fall that doesn't
even include the inflation issues as
well
Joey's okay let's go to you next up but
I want to play for you this sound bite
today because we he mentions title 42 we
haven't mentioned the mass mandates
except for the intro here's President
Biden kind of confusing the two today
no what I'm considering is continuing to
hear from my uh my uh first of all
there's going to be an appeal by the
justice department
because as a matter of principle we want
to be able to be in a position where if
in fact it is strongly concluded by the
scientists that we need title 42 that we
be able to do that oh Joey yeah uh man
Bernie Sanders looking pretty good right
there I mean as far as a candidate goes
the Democrats should recruit Tyler Perry
as who they should recruit you couldn't
beat him that's a Rags the richest story
that's your deep bench for the Democrats
there instead we have this geriatric guy
who can't uh consider the two things
that he's pushing on Americans right now
title 42 should be repealed if you
believe that the pandemic is over if you
believe that the risk to our country
isn't there at the border it's unethical
to use that for a purpose other than
what it's intended for and it's up to
Republicans and Democrats to fix our
immigration system I don't think that we
put Band-Aids on tourniquet problems as
a guy who's needed a tourniquet or two
I'm not a big fan of that tactic
will Republicans win big yeah they'll
win big does that mean they'll win 2024
I remember the Tea Party swing I
remember a lot of swings over the past
10 to 14 years that didn't bear fruit
because at the end of the day once you
have the gavel you're in charge and you
also have responsibility right all right
judge winding you up and setting you
loose well at the table you know the the
truth here is that to those people who
believe that Joe Biden's winning had
more to do with disliking Donald Trump I
would say this
I think America dislikes Joe Biden and I
think the American dislikes Joe Biden
because they're fed up of what he's done
to them and it's exacerbated by the
pandemic I mean everything that he's
done has been struck down whether it's a
mask mandate whether it was a vaccine
mandate whether it was the eviction
moratorium uh whether it was blocking
companies from vaccinating their
employees everything the guy tries to do
is being knocked down in the courts and
he's dragged down the whole party the
the the the the the the crime rate is
it's it's beyond what any of us have
seen in 30 years so I I think that
certainly the Republicans have to have a
plan and they will have a plan there for
Law and Order they're for a border
security uh therefore making sure that
we are independent that we do things and
make things in America and that we don't
support our enemies when it comes to
making products for for America and I in
in the end I think it's as simple as
saying you you know this guy has been a
disaster everything that's happened to
us since he's been the president is a
mess and our lives are just terrible you
talk to anyone they're they're very
unhappy and you know I don't have to
wind up and swing it out it really is a
sad commentary on where we are in this
country he cannot lead that party
anymore and the fact that they don't get
rid of him is stunning to me and you
know what Bernie Sanders may be 80 years
old but you know they stole it from him
with that whole thing with Hillary and
Donna brazile and all that other stuff
you know maybe it is his turn I'm not
saying that I support him but at least
he's smart he's got the energy he knows
what he's doing
ah well but no I was just gonna ask Joey
about his tie because it's it's
disturbing to me it's the closest thing
to Spring in my closet and I'm I'm
bringing the warm weather up here with
me all right we appreciate that it's
giving me flashbacks up next the black
lives matter leader lashing out at a
Democratic mayor after being accused of
ignoring Inner City crime hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else